[Music]  the first day we came we went to visit  the wedded rocks and you know they're  just extraordinary with the target on  top there's just this beautiful kind of  connection that you see with a rope and  the wedded rocks were just for us like  an intriguing concept so to visit that  but also to then visit it unfortunately  after the typhoon and to see that the  rope had been severed you know actually  it was kind of quite moving think what  we're very curious about is seeing again  nature linked to another sister site  literally and it being linked together  through something like the the rope and  is a symbolic way of linking something  together  [Music]